I'd want to be Antarctic but why the
[ __ ] is that Antarctic can do people
from Antarctica aren't they just
Penguins that's just Penguins there's no
humans
[Music]
so imagine there's this mother named
Alta
she's uh been raising this child on her
own after separating from her husband
and needed to uh needed someone to look
after her daughter this daughter named
Melissa while she worked
um she posted an advertisement in the
local paper which is answered when
somebody calling herself Ruth Johnson uh
hits her up and says hey I could take
the job
agreeing to meet with Johnson first
babysitter never showed up in person but
called again and said she'd be right for
the job
in desperate need of a babysitter to
look after her daughter sounds like a
catfish babysitter Alta agreed and a
roommate of hers handed her daughter
Melissa over to the babysitter
and then she was not seen again for 51
years 51 years holy [ __ ] 51 years family
spent decades trying to find Melissa
never giving up on the hope that they
could be reunited with her daughter and
holding birthday parties for her each
year and then they had an empty birthday
they had an empty birthday party how sad
is that yeah they just had to celebrate
the birthday so the whole family was
invited let's [ __ ] celebrate this
empty missing people birthday party
do you think she spent time planning the
birthday now that she learned not to
wing it anymore oh yeah she learned her
lesson yeah that's a tough lesson
I could really spend time on sussing out
this baby I'm thinking I'm gonna wing it
yeah
dude that's like the worst thing ever
isn't it Jesus so Melissa's parents uh
got back together and went on to have
four more children three daughters and a
son Jeff who they you know first told
about his sister when he was six years
old oh hey they got back together yeah
they got back together that's how the
family was able to celebrate or sort of
Celebration give birth to a whole search
party damn
uh with police unsuccessful in solving
Melissa's kidnapping the family ended up
trying to find her themselves turning to
DNA testing in the hopes of uncovering a
match eventually they were finally able
to track down Melissa after a DNA test
from 23andMe found a match with a sample
from father Jeffrey Highsmith they found
Melissa living under the name Melanie
Walden just a few miles away
did she know that that she was having
never known she was a missing person
why would you tell him that you're one
of those missing people
you were adopted it was a great scan we
ran we're kind of criminals you
pretended to be big to know he was
stolen I know you think your parents are
boring but we're kind of criminals
actually yeah we're cool Melissa said
after meeting her real parents she
wanted to change her name back to the
one that they gave her writing a
statement on Facebook saying that uh
I've been stolen I've been stolen it's
exactly what she was she's Hood like
that Melissa sibling Sharon Rose High
Smith said they found her purely because
of DNA and not because of Any police FBI
involvement wow wow 23andMe dude solving
crimes everywhere her pants already dead
did somebody in here do 23andMe I did
I've done 23 over you like 100 of China
yeah I spent 150 for them to tell me um
99 Chinese
exactly one percent is scary though you
know what here's the thing though
because I because my mom would always
she would tell me like oh your your
grandmother is Malay Indo like because
she's from Singapore she was like and my
mom speaks like eight different
languages so is it like a bunch of white
doctors at 23 I mean they're like you're
Chinese so apparently a lot of a lot of
other Asian people that have done it
already have gotten the same thing like
I just I'm just 100 Chinese so
apparently with more people adding to
the pool or more Asians doing the
23andMe then it's able to get better
more accurate like regions where you're
from because at first I got it was 99
Chinese and it said from China South
East Asia like that was the category so
it was China and Southeast Asia and I
was like all right and then a couple
months later it updated to like you're
50 Taiwanese and I was like all right
and then the other 50 on what do you
mean updated like they just send you an
email like oops we were wrong with our
percentages no it's here's another
Nation we now recognize here yeah
they're like taiwan's still not a
country but here's more insight of like
where you never did 23andMe no there's a
constant up there it just updates but
you got to sign in yeah they'll tell you
like oh like uh we found out something
about maybe diabetes that might be
Associated or just like constant you did
23andMe or more family members has yours
changed the first time you did it so
I've logged in so the first time I did
it and then maybe like a year or two
after
um it didn't change within that year or
two so what are you it's like 80
something percent Chinese and then like
three percent Korean uh 12
um some sort of like Native American on
my uh really yeah my dad's four
percent's high yeah it's pretty high you
should have like a casino or something
yeah well it's like South America uh
Native oh they know they never get
recognized yeah they don't get reckons
like old mix or something or Incan
probably because they're from Peru
you're Incan you're like Mayan you're
like
I don't know I think Peru's ink and this
is your people right here is that even
one you're probably good at swimmer oh
damn that's a well it's so it's a 99.9
Chinese 56 0.4 is South Chinese
Taiwanese and then the other one is
South Chinese oh Guangdong so like half
of it is like Cantonese speaking and the
other afternoon that's probably my Mom's
side
and then I'm melanesian melanesian
what's melanasian that's like uh like
Tahiti and [ __ ] oh cool point one
percent you're point one percent
Tahitian yeah you're not gonna get a
discount there my friend from the
islands bro I was uh I was 98 Japanese
one percent Korean and one percent other
and I checked back a month later and
then the Korean disappeared and it was
99 Japanese yeah you're 99 Japanese for
sure dude that's is how does the Korean
disappear it just I guess that's how
they infiltrate it you're eating more
Japanese food maybe maybe I had a little
kimchi the day that I spit gets more
into your pores it's just like that DNA
test things like that depends on what
you're the first three days I like the
idea that when you sign up for 23andMe
and they give you results that that's
their way of getting you to get other
people to do it they're like hey you get
10 other people to sign up you can get
five percent more Europeans 100 23andMe
is a [ __ ] pyramid scheme because
that's the only way it works and then
every now and then it'll be like you
have 11 new relatives and it'll be like
do you even show the same data pool with
like ancestry.com or whatever the [ __ ]
because that's a Gerald is on there yeah
you could hit him up like y'all want to
link up and they're like we're not even
we're like two percent related yeah
they'll tell you like oh yeah we found
four more relatives and it's like your
fifth cousin or some [ __ ] yeah it's
usually fourth to fifth cousin I need to
check I haven't been on it in a minute
is it is there like [ __ ] uh like
liability [ __ ] that you or waivers that
you gotta sign where they where they get
to use your DNA now in like third party
things yeah who knows what they're gonna
do it's like Facebook that's why I
didn't do it [ __ ] yeah but like in on
on South Park though Randy wanted to be
Native American so bad he started making
out with a chief of a tribe it worked
DNA so you can exist that out and claim
uh Native stats so we can get a [ __ ]
uh Casino like this is so [ __ ] funny
that's kind of funny
it's kind of smart too it's a genius
yeah so good if you had to let's all do
it if you had to if you had to have a
different type of ethnicity that's
clearly not in your bloodstream what
would you want to do Nigeria 100 Nigeria
how come I don't know I just feel like
all the Nigerian people I mean are
really smart and really athletic
oh and I need some of that is that why
do you why was that weird you guys all
got quiet why is that weird I don't know
that you knew that many Nigerians beside
the UFC fighters what's up I think
there's definitely a weirdness
I said it too quick is that where all
the runners come from I said it too
quick
Canyons I'd want to be Antarctic but why
the [ __ ] is that Antarctic can do people
from Antarctica are they just Penguins
that's just Penguins there's no humans
like native people researchers
Antarctica there's native people in
antioxide
people lived in North Pole what are you
guys talking about the people live Santa
Santa no not polish North Poland North
polish no like the Inuit cats they don't
have any in Antarctica it's only nice
they do they're called antarcticans oh
really yeah yeah innate an Antarctic kid
is a well by definition fictional or
hypothetical holy [ __ ] I made that up
also
now it sounds weird when I say it
they're probably just studying like
animals and [ __ ] yeah it says especially
a scientist or researcher yeah dude one
who has spent time in Antarctica it's
crazy I love the lore about like the
secret Antarctic and stuff oh bro it's
good what's the lore the lore is like
well it depends on which one like Flat
Earth there's like the Nazi one there's
like the yeah Flat Earth there's a
secret space base what about the hollow
Earth one where there's an entrance
through the Antarctica and you go
through and it's like a Thousand Leagues
Under the Seas that's a good one me and
Nikki talked about that on our podcast
that's a [ __ ] interesting story too
the pilot saw the hole and you went
through it and then there's nowhere like
King Kong and them are yeah yeah yeah no
giants like giant people giant monsters
Godzillas remember how when you looked
at the globe as a kid Antarctica looked
so huge because it's at the bottom it's
all stretched out yep and you thought it
was like dude that's the biggest
freaking continent yeah but it's just
like
Liars dude they just stretched that [ __ ]
out yeah
[Music]